what we're looking at is a graphic
that's put together by the new york
times and it's a way of thinking about
how incomes have grown since 1980.
so before we even look at the various
percentiles of income this black line is
interesting to look at because this is
real per capita gdp and you can see
relative to 1980 real per capita gdp has
grown it looks like about 80 percent
and that's interesting because in theory
if all of the growth of productivity of
a country were evenly distributed then
everyone would be growing on that per
capita gdp line
but what's interesting about this
graphic is we clearly do not see that
so for example folks with incomes in the
90th to 99th percentiles their income
actually is growing in line with per
capita gdp and in the year that this was
compiled that would be someone after
taxes making 120 000 to
425 000 per year after taxes so that's a
good amount of money someone making
000 after taxes might be making roughly
700 000 or even 800 000 before taxes but
we see a spread for people making more
or making less
the folks in the top one percent their
income has grown about twice as fast as
per capita gdp and folks in the 0.01
so this is one out of every 10 000
people their income looks like it has
grown roughly five times faster than gdp
and obviously if some folks incomes are
growing faster than per capita gdp other
folks incomes have to be growing slower
than per capita gdp and we can see that
the middle 40 percent their growth it
looks like it's about two-thirds as fast
as per capita gdp and the bottom 50
percent it looks like their growth is
about a third of per capita gdp now some
folks might say hey this is alarming we
see an increase in inequality as our
economy grows while some might say hey
this is a side effect of capitalism
everyone's income is growing in real
terms but in a capitalist world some
people might grow more than others but
regardless of your point of view it's
interesting to think about why we see
this spread happening and we're not
going to be able to dissect all of it
right now but i'll talk about some of
the areas of interest that might explain
this phenomenon and it's not in any
particular order but some folks would
point to globalization
why would globalization do this well in
a globalized world capital can flow to
wherever they can get the cheapest labor
and so for example if you're someone in
the top one percent or someone in the
0.01 percent and you own a company you
could take your capital to a lower cost
place you don't have to make wages in
your country go up and so the demand for
labor is going to go offshore and so
there will be less demand for labor in
your country so it wouldn't drive wages
up
another possibility that folks could
talk about is technology
technology oftentimes has a similar
effect as globalization instead of
taking labor and taking it offshore to
find cheaper labor technology oftentimes
can replace labor or another way to
think about it it can make folks more
productive so you don't need as much
labor and so the folks who own the
technology or able to take advantage of
technological trends well they might get
a disproportionate amount of that gdp
growth related to both of these is the
idea of education
maybe in a globalized world and a
technology world the payback of
education matters even more and so if
someone doesn't get as much of an
education they can't participate in the
benefits of technology as much or jobs
that they're qualified for go offshore
so they can't demand as high wages
another potential lever to think about
is immigration policy which from a wage
point of view could have a similar
effect as technology or globalization if
you have an increase in supply of lower
skilled labor economics will tell us
that the price for that labor which are
wages would be suppressed
another major lever that folks will
definitely point to is tax policy or
fiscal policy in general for example
generally speaking the ordinary income
tax rates the more money you make become
a higher and higher percentage of your
income but people in the very high
brackets in that top 1 or in that top
100 of a percent
many of their income comes
disproportionately from capital gains
income on asset price appreciation and
that type of income today is taxed at a
significantly lower tax rate than
ordinary income
and then last but not least you have
monetary policy
and this is the actions of the federal
reserve and interest rates and many
times especially when you go through
crises the benefits of lower interest
rates might disproportionately benefit
those who own capital who are in the
position to borrow at those lower
interest rates and then invest it at
higher interest rates and that might
speak to some of these higher brackets
so i'll leave you there the goal of this
video isn't to make a value judgment
over what's good what's bad or what
likely is the case but it's just to get
us thinking about the trends that we are
for sure seeing and what might be the
levers and this isn't an exhaustive list
that might be causing them